hello and welcome to this video I should
switch off there and then it is ok the
window and dbol Dibble matata game one
not so get the modern steinitz again on
the dashing out some fairly quick moves
let's see where we were headed III ok
I'll seize it takes takes night before
he was a bit concerned about about this
one ok I wonder if d 5 is actually
working notice my development is better
but
still doesn't feel like like it should
work yeah I'm a little bit unsure how to
handle those positions if white is just
keeping the tension like that after d5
it's it's clearly a king's indian type
of game but if they play like his he is
doing right right now I'm really unsure
what what blacks ideas I can put
something on their forward it's not
really convincing at least I think white
as although sir all those automatic
moves and I don't don't quite know what
I do Jim if I want to play this on a
more regular basis I have to learn this
for real if somebody can just toss out
those simple simple moves and then worse
that's not that's nobody yeah that
weakens f5 considerably maybe it's just
bad but going back is no option Queen f
6m I could have played 2006 actually now
I should've sure to check that in Jeff 6
not sure if it helped in any regard but
it's something that I should not just
ignore yeah just not a good position
maybe d5 is a moving map and we get am
opening my my old position there for his
pieces that's very bad opening result
okay now at least I know what to do but
i think it was stronger to keep the
tension but if that doesn't mean i'm i
mean would shave him still feels better
for wide and again it's easy to play a
like before and so on that's a very
simple play
[Music]
yeah this is I think kind of playable
it's better for for white again but it's
not doesn't look like a disaster mm you
for doesn't quite work okay let's take
this and go from here night will come
around probably
so here we wants to choose further night
to you for okay yeah I want to play if I
am opening things up maybe also creature
age for attacking civ form yeah at one
point he had to do this so let's see I
can also do b5 probably a four then ok
anyway let's do it he has to be at least
a little bit precise a thing with the
queenside play if he put puts too much
there are 20 pieces on the green side
then I have some counter play here
something like an e4 it takes it
[Music]
I should have to Quincy for huh it's my
idea I don't know if it's any good my
queen doesn't have squares okay so
transform the Queen's reign I have to be
on the lookout at the end there's always
be sure to be six and the seaport is
going to be very dangerous I have to
keep that time morning my queen has no
moves this is a bit of an issue here
[Music]
absolute is no squares for the Queen
yeah i was thinking who gave three but
that doesn't work at all at the end he s
got Quincy form
that's pretty bad yeah somehow I managed
to really put the pieces in the best and
the worst possible squares there the
Queen has no moves I was really terrible
game and he wins here with very simple
moves like anybody can find that that's
the worst thing I mean losing is one
thing but if you make it like easy for
the opponent that's always I think
extremely am extremely annoying Queen f
6 h-6 such v6 is going to be far too
quick
human bishop f 2 g-3 is probably enough
to save it check check nautica Chatwin
yeah that was really bad lack resigned I
was a really terrible game a black gym I
felt like here I mean not that I'm in
good shape here but I felt like I should
be reasonably okay but I completely miss
played that absolutely completely miss
plata be five know what I didn't have on
the radar at all yeah okay I understand
that white is better but I'm not sure if
I should lose in this terrible way like
i did in the game this is the thing yeah
I can kill me with bishop be 6e already
I can hear you form yeah of course that
that's kind of the idea but it looked
very took strange here like this and
then there's again yeah I wanted to get
to get to this but I never did again I
can go before we didn't I do that yeah i
was tempted but this is a Quincy fine I
did not really have this on the Raider
because I felt that this is too simple
but the problem is really that he's so
quickly against this porn what I saw is
is this kind of jelly a shin at this
this and it takes like take a leak and
I'm resigning but okay I don't have to
of course all right it's difficult
it's difficult yeah maybe I can and then
he can go away for I need to get rid of
all the rooks here the otherwise doesn't
make any sense this position without
rooks at the bishop being on the aid is
probably a fortress draw but not very
very nice and now my queen has no
squares the entity just place those
simple moves on the queenside yeah I
just played it very badly just played it
very badly yeah the thing is I'm kind of
unsure how to play this position if why
does not play quick t5 I mean I've seen
many games with the quick d5 and this is
kind of acceptable but I don't really
know what to do here I mean I have some
moves that kind of fit but I don't see a
clear plan what black could do so I
really have to study that I don't think
this should be extremely threatening to
black but you need to know what to do
and it seems I have no good recipe here
yeah GG fibers was kind of already kind
of bad i think i should go green chair 6
this is probably acceptable somehow even
though i'm not happy with the position
ok guys thanks for watching